thank you maurice yes i'm here with
world's
number two fabiano caruana after a
peaceful draw but
very complex game it seems uh like
fabiano take us through it and tell us
who came up with this idea at move
number eight queen to e2 this uh was
played the highest rated that played
this was valentina gooning
actually well it's it's supposed to not
be a very accurate move because
um black trades at night which is a bit
awkward on f5
but it's i thought it's a fresh position
i mean it's not like
i mean black has many good ways to play
this but uh it's very likely that people
haven't
checked it so thoroughly and that's the
main advantage of this line because
once you've checked it i guess they're
you'll find many many good ways for
black to play
did you expect uh onish to go for uh the
berlin or did you expect the dragon
the dragon well he just uh did a
chessboard course uh on the dragon i
haven't thought in chess world courses
um no i thought the berlin might happen
uh and i was actually happy with the
result of the opening because like
around here i thought
i have a tiny bit of an advantage the
most i could really hope for from this
position
um yeah he actually surprised me a bit
going for f5 i thought something like
queen d7
i thought he would wait for g4 or
something like that before he plays f5
because it it felt like this is a
promising position and then i
didn't see anything too great here um
i was like yeah my first intention was
something here
maybe i should have gone for this
position um
queen d7 and okay it's
drawish but but he suffers here because
i have the majority
i have the majority and he has what's
not a very useful point on the queen
side
um but i didn't fully believe that
my winning chances would be great in
this type of position did you feel at
any point that you were getting close to
uh
getting something clear not really i
didn't like that i was retreating
i was just doing it because i thought i
should try to keep some pieces
on the board i was hoping that it would
keep more complexity would give me more
winning chances but
um probably after this i didn't have any
real
yeah this was a nice movie because queen
f2 it looks like he's in huge trouble
because of this
his bishop is but then queen jesus i
mean the same ideas in the game queen
g6's
um he's saving the bishop so maybe i
should
i don't know go for the end game
but it's it shouldn't be much but it's
uh at least i can try to trade rooks and
this could be
potentially dangerous um if i trade
rooks because i do have the majority and
and without any rooks his queensland
really will not get moving
but i think it's it's a very george
position anyway
um and and this was just not
i was somehow
i don't know i've seen this in events i
thought i would have something maybe
some chances to play with after queen he
found this very precise move queen f6
yeah i briefly considered taking this
pawn
uh i thought it's a it's crazy um and
then i started seeing like all sorts of
moves for him and i thought
you know this is not a real winning
attempt um
like yeah i just he could play at bishop
seven i mean he has very long term
compensation um and this end game is
actually close to being
maybe if i could get my king to f4 it
would be um
unpleasant for him but i'm not in time
because king of 2 rook d5
or rookie basically he's attacking my
pawns in time
or rookie 2 rook d4 but like if he
didn't never work before i get my king
to f3 or something and then he really
suffers here
it should still be a draw but he really
suffers
uh and the same if i thought that this
was suffering
but okay computer shows g6 here so it's
also draw but yeah root d4 is very
accurate um
so so maybe i had some slight chances in
this game but
but nothing too major you're going into
uh the second half of the event have a
point behind the leaders
what do you need to do to catch up with
them i should
first try to get a plus score and um
yeah it's uh it's going to be i guess a
tight race um
i should start winning games if i want
to participate in it
what's the plan for the rest day i don't
know yet
there you go there you have it guys back
to you in the studio